Egyptian security forces announced this
morning that they killed 40 suspected
militants following a roadside bomb
blast that left four people dead three
tourists from Vietnam and an Egyptian
guide were killed and at least 10 others
were injured Friday when the explosion
hit their tour bus near Egypt's Giza
pyramids Barry Peterson is in London
with the very latest very good morning
good morning although most of the
terrorists killed were in the area
around Giza authorities are not saying
if the raids were directly connected to
the bus attack the attack came at 6:15
in the evening about two and a half
miles from the Giza pyramids we heard a
big bang says this eyewitness and saw
people running investigators worked to
see how the bus was targeted and now
believed it was an improvised explosive
device attached to a wall detonated as
the bus went by the Vietnamese foreign
ministry issued an angry statement
saying it strongly condemned what had
called this act of terrorism Egypt's
Prime Minister visited the wounded and
hospitals and insisted there is no way
to stop terrorists but it isn't a
country in the world he said that is
100% safe from such a time terrorists
have attacked tourists in the past all
part of an effort to scare tourists away
and disrupt Egypt's lucrative tourism
industry Dana
Barry Petersen thanks Barry